c'est une bataille judiciaire qui dure
depuis plus d'un an
l'enjeu l'équivalent d'un milliard de
dollars de lingots d'or appartenant au
venezuela et de tenues par la banque
d'angleterre malgré les demandes
répétées de nicolás maduro pour le
récupérer
toutes ont été rejetées pour les
britanniques c'est le président par
intérim
autoproclamé roi noailles d'eau qui
al'autorité pour disposer de l'or le
gouvernement britannique reconnaît
monsieur guido en tant que président
constitutionnel par intérim du venezuela
et en vertu de la doctrine une seule
voie la cour doit accepter cette
déclaration comme sans équivoque la
banque centrale du venezuela a aussitôt
annoncé qu'elle allait faire appel de
cette décision qualifiée d' absurde par
le gouvernement de nicolas sma du raw ou
d'un décision c'est une décision absurde
erronée bizarre quand on tente de
valider devant un tribunal une situation
aussi folle scandaleuse est ahurissante
s'étend sur une table à locale un comble
à un sollicités alors au lieu nos
écoutilles bénessois nicolás maduro a
demandé aux instances judiciaires du
venezuela d'ouvrir immédiatement une
enquête afin de déterminer les charges
pénales qui pèsent sur ceux qui
participent à cet acte effrontée de vol
de leur vénézuélien est il intelligent
dès lors et les solins en proie depuis
plusieurs années à une grave crise
économique
le venezuela avait fait savoir qu'il
avait besoin de cet argent pour lutter
contre la pandémie de coronavirus faut
pour le défenseur du conseil
d'administration alternative de la
banque centrale vénézuélienne nommé par
wang wei dos mais invalidée par la cour
suprême
mettant en avant le risque l'or soit
dilapidé au profit du gouvernement de
nicholas maduro pour prouver sa bonne
foi
les autorités avaient alors proposé que
l'or soit transférée directement
programme des nations unies pour le
développement au venezuela
la population ne comprend pas et réclame
les trente et une tonnes d'or détenues
par les anglais ce qu'ils font est un
acte de piraterie de pillage de vol
alors que nous avons besoin de notre
argent pour acheter des traitements et
des médicaments pour lutter contre le
coc vide lors qu'il est en angleterre et
au peuple vénézuélien
1 ce n'est à personne d'autre ni à
bouaye d'eau ou au gouvernement c'est au
peuple donc le peuple vénézuélien
lui-même défendra sa richesse est la
politesse à qui et la richesse de tout
le peuple vénézuélien et nous nous
battrons pour que cette richesse
reviennent au moins des vénézuéliens le
résultat de ces audiences pourrait
constituer un précédent pour les autres
font vénézuélien bloqués à l'étranger
notamment dans les pays européens
la représentante de rois de why do à
londres a d'ailleurs déclaré que la
décision sur d'autres recours dans
d'autres pays n'avait pas encore été
prise mais qu'elle serait prochainement